known her forever this next guest i've
known her
longer than i've known like my you know
the people that i kind of hang
you know she's like she goes way back
and she is um
probably one of those uh reliable
comedians that i've used
in my past you know i mean in terms of
when i need help in terms of the
writings
because in the writings right i get
flustered
you know i mean and there were times
where i would have i would need quick
jokes
right because i was doing some sort of
panel show mostly
chelsea lately and i would call this
next guest
and she would meet me at like either a
coffee bean right the one over there by
the
laugh factory right and we would do
sessions
and you were so helpful i mean you
because in that time of my career i was
so desperate i had nothing going on
and she was just one of those people
that i could always rely on and oh you
know not only is she a writer
she's one of the best stand-ups in the
country i believe and she's open for me
before as well
um and she um
you know recently was the head writer
for the david spade
show lights out on the netflix
but then the pandemic hit that went awry
um she was uh
also a producer on the david smith show
right
and uh she's written on a lot of things
she's a great stand-up podcaster she's
everything
i've known her the longest i ca i think
she's one of the
longest people i've known in the whole
world
sarah tiana never run away
how are you guys you've been on a short
list to do this and i don't know why
you haven't have we asked you before you
asked me once
i think and i um there was something
going on with my family or i i was doing
something then i and i couldn't make it
and i was so bummed because
i've been i mean i i love both of you i
love this podcast i love everything
you're doing i can't believe you're
actually doing a podcast
and that you've committed to something
for so long i know
it's delilah so i'm like oh i'm like i
have to go see this in person
yeah that i know it's real and it's not
just an instagram story
i know it's it's you know it's like you
know i
there's two things that i've committed
to in my life three things
right i've committed to kalila i've come
into this podcast i've committed to
stand up
but everything else i've never committed
to you're committed like acting
when you're filming no i'm just kidding
i'm just no you're so good
i thought you would laugh at that
you're just like a naturally talented
person well you know i think i'm just
like a weird
funny guy i guess i'm a weird leaf just
a weird guy
from the time from
since you've known him the longest yeah
um have you seen
an evolution or has he generally been
the same
yeah i definitely have seen an evolution
of bobby i mean when i've i've met you
19 years ago
yeah i was thinking about it on the way
here yeah when i had first started doing
stand-up and you remembered me from mad
tv because i had been like a little i
had like a little role on mad tv when i
first started and he remembered me
and uh the first week i i have to say i
think i did hit on you maybe did i hit
on you
you never acted on it oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah maybe i was being a little flirty
in the beginning
to say that you're flirty and hitting on
doesn't translate to women like we don't
know that you're doing it that's so rude
but i would i would have been into it no
but i think you're really he's polite
and he's not a
creep right so sometimes you're yeah
there's always these
because here's what it's because what it
is
what no for me though is what it's i i
don't like being rejected
no but the way you do it too like i
remember the first text message he sent
me after our first
coffee date yeah yeah it was really
sweet you said i really
enjoy hanging out with you that's it it
wasn't like
great yeah and it was simple i was like
this is so nice yeah yeah
does he like me yeah those guys are like
hey let me see your no you know what i
mean
also it's like a neuter also when i'm
and also when i make love
mm-hmm yeah i mean i'm very christian
about it very christian yeah i mean i'm
like put the sheet on the body
in the dark in the dark i cut a hole
through the little sheet right
and i go close your eyes right then i
close my eyes then i put my hands on the
mattress like this i'll do three like
very like mormon pumps
what do i call them mormon puns yeah i
do like three quick mormon palms
and i go um i did it yeah i mean
i relieved myself inside you right and
then i go to sleep
you know i'm very christian about it
creepy hey
that really turned crazy i've ever heard
in my life yeah yeah
no i mean i feel like that's not the
bobby eye
i mean i thanked you in my first album
like you were on like the cover
like on the back of the cover i think
like three people like my parents
and bobby oh that's so funny because you
made me the comedian that i
like you would make what did i do
anything yes you did you would make
people put me up when i couldn't get
stage time anywhere
yeah whenever you did a show you would
bring me along and you would make them
put me up in order for you to go up and
at the time you were on mad tv i mean it
was like a big deal
yeah so i was like this is the cool like
i can't believe i know bobby lee
you know and yeah the comedy store was
like a whole different story though
so that was that's harder yeah that's a
harder kill yeah but you always gave me
always you always gave me very blunt and
good advice and i always appreciated
that and i i think
because though um number one at that
time
would you say that it was far more
difficult for women
yeah especially at the store there was
like some sexism going on right was it
yeah
some yeah
[Laughter]
yeah all of it it was harder and i just
feel like you know you need a champion
right that yeah you know yeah because i
view women as like i view
i guess a minority maybe yeah
yeah yeah because in a way we are like
we are a very small group
that you know um that also
i i would i think like back when i
started too like there wasn't really
a space for you as a woman to be like
to have like a lane like now i feel like
certain like women have different lanes